In debugging, simplicity eases our lives from the very beginning.
As an example, consider bug reports.
If you ever maintain a big piece of software with dozens and dozens
and maybe even thousands and thousands of users,
you may have gotten feedback from users--that is, bug reports.
In the early 2000s, I coauthored a debugger named GNU DDD.
It was pretty successful, so it had many users and I also got lots and lots of bug reports from the field.
These bug reports--even in these early times--of course came electronic mail.
But I'm drawing actual snail mail, because it's cuter.
Some of these bug reports would just contain the required information,
such as the steps needed to reproduce the problem
as well as the observed behavior,
but then there would also be people who would send in their entire programs
that they were currently debugging.
Some would send in their entire home directory or even the contents of their entire hard disk
just in case this would be needed to reproduce the problem.
And others would send in just the one liner, "Your program crashed,"
which was less information than I would need.
What you'd like to have in a bug report is information that is relevant.
Here relevant means if it's different then it changes the behavior.
Of course, when users are submitting bug reports
they don't necessarily know whether their information changes the behavior,
so to stay on the safe side they supply more information than would actually be required,
but in order to have a simple bug report or a simple test case,
we want information in there to be relevant.
This calls for a quiz.
When we simplify a test case, just as we did before for the HTML input,
then everything is what?
Simple, correct, relevant, or elegant? Over to you.